for the past 160-ish years virginia has
been going through a bit of a breakup
as you know west virginia broke away
from the state during the american civil
war and yet even when the war was over
the two
never reunited which raises the question
why
why didn't the virginias get back
together so to begin when the civil war
broke out many in virginia did not wish
to join the confederacy as its leaders
in richmond had declared
as such a couple of conventions were
called in wheeling which first
established a brand new union recognized
government for virginia led by francis
pierpont and second called for the
immediate secession of these western
territories from virginia and the
creation of a new state
and that new state was to be known as
kanoha it wasn't long before delegates
chose the name west virginia instead
normally breaking away from a state
would be impossible since the state's
government would need to agree to the
separation
but since pierpont was seen as the
legitimate leader of all of virginia
that wasn't a problem the problem came
with the necessary referendum on west
virginia's new constitution and
existence as a state
the issue was that many areas within the
new state to be had supported secession
and were home to many slave owners who
were not too keen on joining the
abolitionist union
when the vote was held many areas were
occupied by union troops which in the
eyes of many affected the outcome
the areas polled voted to approve the
new constitution and to become a brand
new state
mostly because those opposed boycotted
the vote and soon after this these areas
were transferred to west virginia by
pierpont's government
this wasn't simply done for kicks but
because these areas have been listed
under the constitution as potential
parts of the state
in 1863 these two counties were further
added giving west virginia its
modern-day borders
and in the same year lincoln and
congress agreed to west virginia
becoming a state and it formally joined
the usa
so spoiler alert the union won the war
and after the confederacy's defeat there
were some that raised the question of
what was to be done with virginia and
west virginia
in 1866 the virginian government now
back in richmond asked its west
virginian opposite if it wanted to be
reincorporated back into virginia proper
to which the leaders of west virginia
shockingly said no
so that's all sorted right well no
whilst virginia couldn't regain all of
west virginia it hoped for the return of
some territory specifically these two
counties
and there were two main arguments for
this the first was that congress hadn't
approved the county's transfer until
1866 which was after the virginian
government had returned to richmond in
1865 and repealed most of pierpont's
government's legislation
which meant that congress had approved
the transfer of land from one state to
another without the consent of both
states
the second argument was that these
counties were occupied by union troops
instead of allowing a vote simply sent
delegates to wheeling to say yes and
thus it wasn't legitimate
this went to the supreme court in 1870
who the next year rejected virginia's
claim on the basis of you were rebelling
so shut up
the court ruling against virginia marked
the final attempt to change the status
of the two states
the usa would be left with two virginias
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons
james bissonette kelly moneymaker danny
maloney marvin castell the pastry
section rob waterhouse moe aaron the
white james castaneda jordan longley
gustav swan marcus asner jerry lamdin
brasheed ali cooling castleman spilling
three plates david silverman maggie
paxkowski coppertone
izzy spencer lightfoot phobojo matthew
shipley robert wetzel lexi schwinn and
winston caywood